se enfrenta a rusia la mayor tormenta
económica de los últimos 20 años
esperaba el presidente ruso vladimir
putin un castigo económico político y
militar tan grande podrá la economía
rusa resistir esta especie de tsunami
hasta dónde están dispuestos a llegar
los aliados atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pues q ha llevado a cabo la mayor
ofensiva militar en europa desde 1945
una ofensiva que nos ha dejado imágenes
que creíamos nunca jamás volveríamos a
ver en la vieja europa nos equivocamos
los tanques la artillería pesada los
combates aéreos o el bombardeo de
ciudades están de vuelta claro que en
esta ocasión lejos de recibir los
vítores los elogios y la aclamación
popular por las victorias en el campo de
batalla putin se ha encontrado con un
enorme tsunami de pérdidas condenas y
castigos a lo largo y ancho de todo el
mundo la invasión rusa de ucrania marca
un punto de inflexión amenaza todo el
orden de posguerra en esta situación
tenemos el deber de ayudar en lo posible
a ucrania a defenderse del ejército
invasor de vladimir putin olaf scholz
canciller de alemania
japón demostrará que la violencia tiene
un alto costo la comunidad internacional
cree que ya no puede mantener la misma
relación con rusia después de su
invasión fumiaki sita primer ministro de
japón los aliados lo advirtieron una y
otra y otra vez
la cruel e injustificada invasión de
ucrania tendría consecuencias
devastadoras para la sociedad la
economía y también para el propio
ejército ruso queridos amigos amigas en
este vídeo os vamos a contar exactamente
cómo los eeuu la unión europea y en
general todos los aliados de la otan
buscan dañar erosionar y hasta destruir
la economía así como buena parte del
poder de rusia y ojo porque quieren
conseguirlo a pesar de que el oso ruso
continuará siendo un importantísimo
exportador de petróleo gas natural y
materias primas así que el reto es
enorme
[Música]
la pregunta es cómo demonios hacerlo de
qué forma se le puede parar los pies a
vladimir putin como están castigando a
los aliados a rusia por la invasión de
ucrania pues bien veámoslo pero un
momento porque sois muchos los que nos
habéis preguntado si existe alguna forma
de colaborar con ucrania en esta guerra
y lo cierto es que si además demostrar
vuestra condena la invasión y el banco
central de ucrania está aceptando
donaciones de todo el mundo para apoyar
a las fuerzas armadas y la resistencia
ucraniana esto evidentemente no es
publicidad nadie nos paga por decir esto
lo hacemos a título meramente
informativo porque pensamos que os puede
ser útil así que si os interesa
contribuir de esta forma os dejamos el
enlace en la descripción
[Música]
expulsando a rusia de la economía
mundial
[Música]
la guerra se libra en muchos frentes de
batalla distintos y uno de ellos es
precisamente el de la guerra económica
en eeuu el reino unido y la unión
europea fueron muy claros si putin
invadía ucrania rusia se enfrentaría a
un castigo sin precedentes y sabéis que
dicho y hecho esto es exactamente lo que
están haciendo ojos no sólo para
intentar parar la guerra sino también y
quizás sobre todo para limitar el poder
la amenaza y la influencia de rusia si
la invasión de ucrania ha dejado algo
claro es que al final un país con pocos
recursos tiene muchas limitaciones e
insuficientes suministros equipos viejos
mala instrucción y un largo etcétera de
problemas de todo tipo por mucha
propaganda que haya la realidad se
termina imponiendo
[Música]
rusia es un país relativamente pobre y
muy corrupto así que su ejército por muy
grande que sea tiene más agujeros que un
queso gruyère es algo que todos hemos
podido ver a la hora de la verdad las
fuerzas armadas rusas padecen carencias
de todo tipo lo que por supuesto tiene
consecuencias por ejemplo todo apunta a
que durante apenas los cinco o seis
primeros días de la invasión los rusos
sufrieron en ucrania más bajas que eeuu
en afganistán durante 20 años
[Música]
pues bien tal y como ya os contamos el
objetivo es castigar a putin y limitar
la capacidad económica de rusia mientras
este país siga siendo hostil claro que
puede que muchos digáis sí sí enrique
estas son las típicas cosas que se dicen
que suenan muy geoestratégicamente
inteligente pero que luego a la hora de
la verdad terminan en prácticamente nada
pues amigos podéis creerme si os digo
que esta vez los aliados van muy pero
que muy en serio la invasión de ucrania
lo ha cambiado todo y para ello su
primer objetivo ha sido arrancar de
cuajo a rusia del sistema financiero
internacional para lograrlo las
potencias occidentales han puesto sobre
la mesa tres vías de actuación
en primer lugar las sanciones han
buscado reducir la financiación
extranjera para el gobierno los bancos y
las empresas rusas para hacerlo los
aliados han aprobado limitaciones a la
compra de deuda y sanciones contra los
principales bancos del país por ejemplo
eeuu ha bloqueado entre varios otros a
los dos principales bancos del país el
sberbank y el vtb que juntos controlan
casi el 60 por ciento del sistema
financiero ruso y que ya no pueden
operar con bancos norteamericanos
es decir que no pueden hacer operaciones
en dólares y claro la mayor parte de las
operaciones internacionales se realizan
precisamente en dólares y además no se
trata sólo de eeuu el reino unido y la
unión europea han hecho también lo
propio vamos que les han dejado
tiritando luego la segunda vía de
actuación ha sido quizás la más esperada
de todas la expulsión de muchos bancos
rusos del conocido como sistema swift el
sistema de mensajería internacional que
conecta la mayoría de bancos del mundo
[Música]
el swift una cooperativa con sede en
bélgica es un sistema de comunicación
interbancario que participa en más de la
mitad de todos los pagos
transfronterizos de alto valor cada día
tramita más de 40 millones de mensajes
financieros entre más de 11.000
instituciones financieras de todo el
mundo
[Música]
pues bien ahora una buena parte de los
bancos rusos quedarán excluidos de este
sistema y ojo porque cuando en 2012 se
expulsó a los bancos iraníes del swift
estos sufrieron una catástrofe de
repente ya no podían gestionar las
transferencias internacionales porque no
podían comunicar las no podían verificar
las en el caso de russian no todos los
bancos estarán afectados o al menos no
de forma completa al fin y al cabo los
europeos pues quieren seguir comprando
el petróleo y el gas ruso y para ello
tienen que poder pagarlo además luego
están las deudas que los rusos tienen
contraídas con los bancos occidentales
que por supuesto éstos quieren recuperar
hablamos de unos 121 mil millones de
dólares pero sea como sea el daño al
sistema financiero ruso será más que
considerable porque si existen
alternativas al swift pero son más caras
entrañan problemas de control y a muchos
bancos nunca les va a compensar
utilizarlas así que de una forma u otra
los bancos rusos excluidos dejarán de
tener acceso a una parte importante del
sistema financiero mundial lo que podéis
haceros una idea complicará y encarecerá
el comercio la inversión extranjera o
sin ir más lejos la gestión de las
remesas vamos una patada enorme
[Música]
y luego por último tenemos la tercera
vía de actuación amigos la expulsión del
swift ha sido la sanción más mediática
de todas sin embargo un momento porque
el auténtico golpe ha sido la decisión
de eeuu la unión europea el reino unido
y canadá a los que puede que se sumen
otros países de bloquear al banco
central de rusia y con ello la mayor
parte de sus reservas internacionales y
es que ver ahí sale como os contamos en
un pasado vídeo una de las grandes bazas
con las que contaban vladmir putin que
eran los más de seiscientos mil millones
de dólares en reservas que rusia había
acumulado durante los últimos años en
forma de dólares euros oro yuanes yenes
etcétera etcétera fijaos
[Música]
pues bien ahora gran parte de estas
enormes reservas ya no están al menos
del gobierno ruso y ya no puede echar
mano de ellas esta es una especie de
bomba nuclear financiera que está
cayendo sobre rusia la guerra llegó y el
dinero se esfumó el dinero se perdió
antes de que la guerra terminara sergei
al 'cash en co ex viceministro de
finanzas y ex vicegobernador del banco
central de rusia las reservas amigos
hacen falta para pagar las importaciones
y también para apoyar la moneda local
por ejemplo ante la huida de capitales y
la salida de inversiones que están
provocando la guerra y las sanciones
ahora el banco central de rusia ya no
tiene los recursos necesarios como para
apoyar el rublo lo que hará que este se
desplome asestando con hay un duro golpe
a todo el país de inflación se disparará
por las nubes los ingresos reales se
desplomaran y los ahorros bueno el valor
de los ahorros se volatilizaron los
argentinos conocen muy pero que muy bien
todo este proceso simple y llanamente de
golpe y porrazo de la noche a la mañana
el bloqueo del banco central le ha
arrebatado el equivalente a cientos de
miles de millones de dólares al gobierno
ruso hablamos de una medida que hasta
ahora sólo se había tomado contra irán
venezuela y corea del norte y rusia vaya
club al que te has apuntado por supuesto
todo esto obliga el gobierno ruso a
tomar medidas algunas de ellas muy
severas
no
al poco de anunciarse en las principales
sanciones el banco central ruso para
intentar frenar la huida de capitales
tuvo que subir los tipos de interés al
20 por ciento desde el 9 y medio
anterior esto por supuesto tiene un
efecto muy negativo sobre las empresas y
las familias rusas el gobierno también
ha tenido que imponer un férreo control
de capitales que por ejemplo impide que
los rusos puedan enviar dinero al
extranjero libremente o que los
inversores internacionales liquiden sus
inversiones en la bolsa rusa
y ojo porque no sólo hablamos de eeuu el
reino unido o la unión europea muchos
otros países como japón corea del sur
australia canadá noruega o si no aportan
bien están imponiendo sanciones a rusia
qué demonios hasta la neutral suiza se
ha sumado a patear al gobierno de putin
suiza respalda las sanciones completas
de la unión europea contra rusia el
fondo petrolero de 13 billones de
dólares de noruega abandonará sus
inversiones rusas pero aquí amigos no
termina todo porque una vez que los
aliados están expulsando a rusia del
sistema financiero internacional ahora
también quieren aislar la atentos
[Música]
lucía más sola que nunca
veréis junto a las sanciones financieras
los aliados también están aprobando
sanciones comerciales que por ejemplo le
impiden a rusia comprar productos
críticos como por ejemplo componentes
tecnológicamente avanzados al mismo
tiempo el riesgo de violar alguna que
otra sanción y el riesgo reputacional
está haciendo que muchas empresas hayan
anunciado que van a cancelar todas o
buena parte de sus operaciones en rusia
este es por ejemplo el caso de volvo
daimler disney jaguar bps el equinos
intel ups fedex a md entre otras muchas
muchísimas y por supuesto el país
también está siendo suspendido de todo
tipo de organismos y competiciones
culturales y deportivas desde eurovisión
hasta el mundial de fútbol la fifa y la
uefa suspenden a todos los clubes y a la
selección nacional pero si hay un campo
en el que se comienza a ver que supone
realmente el aislamiento de rusia ese no
es otro que la aviación
[Aplausos]
tanto la unión europea como el reino
unido y canadá han cerrado su espacio
para los aviones rusos nuestro espacio
aéreo estará cerrado a todos los aviones
rusos y eso también incluye los aviones
privados de los oligarcas ursula von der
leyen presidenta de la comisión europea
y no sólo eso los aliados también han
establecido fuertes restricciones a la
venta de todos los bienes y tecnología
vinculados a las aeronaves es decir que
si un avión va a rusia y por ejemplo
tiene un problema la aerolínea se
arriesga a quedarse tirada por no poder
conseguir las piezas que necesita por
eso muchas compañías internacionales
están suspendiendo sus vuelos a rusia y
aún más la unión europea también ha
prohibido que las compañías de leasing
de aviones trabajen con aerolíneas rusas
y ojo porque más de la mitad de las
aeronaves comerciales en rusia son
precisamente arrendadas que por otra
parte es una operativa muy normal en la
industria vamos que entre unas cosas y
otras los cielos de rusia se van a
quedar muy pero que muy vacíos
[Música]
podemos decir amigos que rus está siendo
expulsada de lleno de la comunidad
internacional y desde luego sin dinero
sin comunicaciones y con restricciones
de todo tipo ya me diréis qué futuro
tiene su economía qué queréis que os
diga pintaba mal muy mal para putin y
para rusia
luego además de todas las sanciones
financieras y comerciales el trío de
aliados eeuu la unión europea y el reino
unido han puesto en el 'ariana' también
a los oligarcas rusos próximos al
kremlin y a los pesos pesados del
gobierno a muchos de ellos les van a
investigar les van a congelar activos y
prohibir la entrada y sabéis que hasta
mónaco se ha sumado a esta línea de
trabajo
estamos apuntando a los aviones privados
de los oligarcas atacaremos sus
propiedades y apuntaremos a otras
posesiones que tienen listas secretaria
de relaciones exteriores de gran bretaña
así que no se nos resulta extraño que
estén siendo precisamente los oligarcas
los primeros que empiezan a cuestionar
la invasión en el entorno del mismísimo
putin los principales oligarcas rusos
están hablando en contra de la guerra en
ucrania ayayay con lo bien que vivían
esta queridos amigos es la otra guerra
la guerra que está librando los aliados
contra rusia pero hablamos de una guerra
el castigo también alcanza el campo
militar si lo habéis oído bien atentos
más armas y armas un arsenal enorme
vladimir putin se las veía muy pero que
muy felices el ejército ucraniano no
podría hacer nada contra la formidable
movilización rusa sin embargo como todos
sabéis la historia ha sido totalmente
diferente las tropas usadas se han
encontrado con un ejército mucho más
robusto y mejor equipado de lo que
pensaban
y no sólo eso tras la invasión los
suministros de los países otan y aliados
comenzaron a llegar como si no hubiera
mañana si al principio países como
alemania eran reacios a suministrar
armas a ucrania de hecho llegaron
incluso a vetar las entregas que otros
países como estonia querían hacer de
armamento fabricado en alemania pero
luego todo cambió de repente las
presiones de eeuu el reino unido polonia
o los países bálticos surtieron efecto
ahora todos se han dado cuenta de que
cada día que los super - resistan las
cosas se ponen peor mucho peor para
rusia
la inmensa mayor parte de los gobiernos
europeos están anunciando grandes
entregas de armas al ejército de ucrania
armas antitanque sistemas de defensa
aérea municiones suministros
alimenticios chalecos rifles etcétera
etcétera e incluso la propia unión
europea ha anunciado que va a utilizar
su fondo para la paz para financiar la
compra de armamento para ucrania
armamento entre el que se incluyen cazas
mig-29 operados por algunos estados
miembros y que los pilotos ucranianos
saben pilotar es la primera vez en toda
la historia que la unión europea destina
fondos a la adquisición de armas
y todo esto por supuesto ha hecho que el
ejército ucraniano pueda resistir mejor
y cause grandes daños al ejército ruso
un ejército al que cada día de combate
le cuesta una fortuna que no tiene y
muchas muchísimas bajas hasta suecia se
ha sumado ahora a esta enorme campaña el
país escandinavo por ejemplo se ha
comprometido a enviar más de 5000
misiles antitanque y miles de chalecos y
cascos entre otros equipos de hecho
prácticamente las únicas excepciones han
sido hungría que se ha comprometido a
donar miles de litros de combustible
pero no armas y españa- que ha enviado
un cargamento con algunos chalecos
algunos cascos y muchos guantes batas y
mascarillas y mascarillas cosas de la
política española
el caso queridos amigos es que así es
como eeuu la unión europea el reino
unido y todos los aliados quieren
castigar a rusia por desatar el horror
de la guerra en ucrania y de paso
limitar su amenaza futura pero llegados
hasta aquí turno para ti qué te parece
la estrategia que están siguiendo los
países aliados que crees que tendrían
que hacer funcionará o no funcionará
déjanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios y
ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like y
suscribirte abisal político desde aquí y
mucho muchísimo ánimo a todo el pueblo
ucraniano un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]